en fait dans cet environnement là est
particulièrement agréable parce qu'on a
une lumière assez douce
dans le cloître de l'abbaye de la
trinité de vendôme s'élève deux oeuvres
en aluminium sculpté monochrome une
belle entrée en matière avant de
découvrir l'exposition de jean paul
moscovino ces deux oeuvres que l'on a pu
apprécier dans la cour du cloître
s'intitule mambo et java et donc comme
leurs titres l'indiquent font allusion
au corps en mouvement au couple aussi et
donc ce qui est un peu un prétexte au
déroulement de la forme et donc de son
jeu dans l'espace et avec la lumière
philippe airs thoniers professeur d'arts
plastiques et médiateur culturel connaît
l'artiste depuis 20 ans il a comme
installer cette exposition au musée de
vendôme il est littéralement tombé
amoureux des oeuvres de jean paul
moscovino et de sa vision épurée du
corps quand on n'est pas dans une
logique de figuration de représentation
pure et simple mais ce côté
anthropomorphique l'allusion ou encore
il le suggère il le il est pas dans
l'anecdote en fait mais c'est une sorte
de prétexte à l'articulation des formes
au jeu de la matière de la couleur et de
la lumière
toutes ces sculptures de métal sont
élaborés à partir d'une seule feuille de
couleur et c'est ce matériau que
l'artiste découpe courbe plie et déplie
pour une aventure entre forme et contre
forme sur certaines je trouve que il ya
des suivants les angles de vue on a des
des musulmans de perspectives qui sont
assez étonnants qui pourrait faire
penser à des gravures des chaires un
petit peu on sait plus trop où ça
commence à s'affiner qu'est-ce qui est
trop casquette en
balance et c'est intéressant jean paul
moscovino pratique le pliage comme des
origamis il sculpte la couleur comme on
joue avec une épluchure pour
reconstituer le fruit à 75 ans il
propose ici une exposition qui lui
ressemble humble simple et sobre